Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu u k w unsere kleine welt ich bin's wieder.
Und ihr werdet euch schon fast gedacht haben mir ist immer noch kein richtig tolles neues thema eingefallen und so setzen wir unsere kleine serie fort über den brexit.
Bisschen habe ich gelogen andere themen sind tatsächlich jetzt auch in vorbereitung.
Nachdem mein auslandsaufenthalt abgeschlossen ist gibt's jetzt wieder ein bisschen mehr kapazität aber andere sachen nachzudenken aber trotzdem wir haben uns wieder zusammengefunden ich begrüße den john john hallo.
Hallo mal wieder.
Ja ist irgendwas passiert.
Wir haben die die krise ist noch voll im gange in großbritannien seite unsere letzte diskussion ja aber eine lösung für diese ganze berichte situation ist leider immer noch nicht in sicht,
aber das können wir jetzt heute dann ein bisschen weiter diskutieren.
Vielleicht kurz nochmal erwähnen also die letzte sendung ist aufgenommen und veröffentlicht worden am zwölften april als wir den termin ausgemacht hatten wussten wir ja noch nicht so richtig was
wird denn da sagen können wir aber tatsächlich extrem gut terminiert weil zu dem zeitpunkt war dann klar,
der brexit wird abermals verschoben auf den einunddreißigsten oktober zweitausendneunzehn halloween brexit und außerdem ein tag vorher am,
elften april hat okay auch klein beigeben und angekündigt dass sie jetzt an der europawahl teilnehmen würden denn,
das resultiert sozusagen daraus wenn sie weiterhin mitglied der,
europäischen union sind mussten sie natürlich auch an diesen wahlen teilnehmen und das haben sie dann halt auch getan,
das ganze fand dann statt am dreiundzwanzigsten mai in,
großbritannien die ganze eu war hat sich ja in europa über drei tage hinweg gezogen.
Erst am ende wurden die ergebnisse offiziell bekannt gegeben aber es war dann relativ schnell klar in ok wie die nummer denn dann gelaufen ist,
ja und.
Es kam ein wenig so wie man es schon hätte befürchten können aber auch hoffen können also es gab ja sowohl eine stärkung der.
Ich weiß nicht ob man von einer remain airlines sprechen kann aber zumindest von den parteien die halt 'ne relativ klare position also generell haben eigentlich die gewonnen die eine klare position haben und das war halt weder laber noch die tore.
Das ergebnis war einfach dann dass die die diese neue formation die brexit party von,
war größte partei mit knapp unter dreißig prozent der abgegebenen stimmen
dahinter waren dann die liberalen die kamen dann richtig stark zurück die grünen haben auch gut gepunktet
und dann die zwei traditionellen parteien laber und die konservativen die lagen deutlich hinter die anderen also die konservativen so eine traditionellen so an der größte partei großbritannien hat nur neun prozent abgegebenen stimmen gekriegt bei der europawahl
man muss auch sagen wahlbeteiligung war relativ gering in großbritannien weil dieses europawahlen großbritannien war in letzter minute organisiert
wahlbeteiligung lag immer noch unter vierzig prozent also man sah in großbritannien keine erhöhte wahlbeteiligung wie in deutschland zum beispiel
aber die parteien die eine klare brexit position hatten die brexit partei auf meine seite und liberalen und grüne auf der anderen seite.
Die haben dann ein super gutes ergebnis dann gekriegt.
Also man kann sagen dass eigentlich die tory und die bella die auch nicht bereit waren jetzt was anderes zu wählen einfach zu hause geblieben.
Und der rest ist dann halt los marschiert und das hat ja ein paar ganz interessante seiten ergebnisse also erstmal ist die
stärker es war ja zum beispiel nicht ganz klar würde jetzt die liberale demokraten davon profitieren würde leber in irgendeiner form auch noch davon profitieren können
und was ist mit den grünen was ist mit change day dieser splitter bewegung die jetzt irgendwie auch schon wieder so ein bisschen.
Ja dass die diese dieses blätter bewegung ist fast schon tot jetzt die haben noch offiziell
vier abgeordneten in den britischen unterhaus wie diese letzte podcast gemacht haben den april was damals schon,
also man sah die die es gab auch eine partei interne urwahl bei den liberalen die haben jetzt eine neue parteivorsitzende reden windsor also es geht jetzt deutlich besser für die liberalen also den bedarf diese neue formation sekunden oder
das gibt's ja nicht
also und und die haben keine angeordnet gekriegt bei der bei der europawahl also und einige change day abgeordneten sind schon zu den liberalen gewechselt also
diese idee eine neue partei zu gründen das debattieren jetzt fast keine leute.
Ja das heißt man kann eigentlich sagen der gewinner aus diesem ganzen spiel sind die liberale demokraten auf der einen seite.
Ja und fragen die brexit partei auf der anderen seite weil und die.
Die frage ist dann was für ein einfluss,
haben diese haben diese parteien dann auf den alltäglichen plättchen situation in großbritannien also was für eine auswirkung auf der brexit weil,
was das europäische parlament da machen kann in sachen brexit ist relativ begrenzt also die muss nicht auswärts abkommen abstimmen zustimmen aber.
Außerdem die haben wenig einfluss auf den alltäglichen brexit prozedere,
das wichtigste daran es war theresa may die ehemalige premierministerin
sie wusste dass es eine katastrophales ergebnis für die konservativen war und sie trat dann schon am vierundzwanzigsten mai also am tag nach der europawahl in großbritannien schon zurück,
weil es ist noch
ordentlich lief für die konservativen in den meinungsumfrage also die konservativen waren noch bei dreißig oder fünfunddreißig prozent noch im januar dieses jahr das ist noch ordentlich lief für die konservativen
in den meinungsumfrage war es dann noch okay für theresa may als die konservativen da nur neun prozent abgegebenen stimmen gekriegt haben bei der europawahl da war es dann schon
ende für theresa may also das war die die das wichtigste auswirkungen auf die brexit situation in großbritannien von dieses europa war
also dann direkt danach steh stieg dann die konservativen in dieser partei interne oval prozedere um theresa mays nachfolge
zu kriegen also das war dann auf die diese ganze brexit geschichte das größte auswirkung auf auf auf auf auf brexit.
Wir sind jetzt so die wahrnehmung der lip teams also man hat ja auch so den eindruck es gibt derzeit nach wie vor kein anderes
thema was in irgendeiner form bestimmt ist also egal was man jetzt irgendeiner potenziellen sonstigen politischen entwicklung,
groß sagt als partei ist es irgendwie alles vollkommen überschattet von der brexit position.
Alles in großbritannien
bei fast alle parteien ist von brexit überschattet also wenn die die konservativen not laber für süden über etwas anderes reden dass das geht
hallo nicht also die reaktion ist immer
im moment mal also wovon kommt das geld für sowas weil wir wissen nicht wie brexit ausgeht also das vertritt,
parteien und die liberalen die versuchen doch nicht andere politikfelder zu erläutern es ist höchste priorität für den einfach mal okay,
brexit zu stoppen ist unser höchstes priorität und so reagiert die partei gerade es ist so volle brexit opposition pur und die haben auch muss man sagen die haben auch ein bisschen erfahrung damit.
Wahlen hatten ja jetzt auch durchaus eine auswirkung also nicht nur die wahlen in okay sondern generell die europawahlen
sind ja auch in etwa so gelaufen wie es schon sich abgezeichnet hat die grünen sind insgesamt sehr viel stärker geworden nicht nur in deutschland sondern sozusagen auch als koalition im europaparlament
und ähnliches da sehen wir irgendwie auch so ein so ein allgemeines muster ne das halt einfach sowohl die der konservative block als auch der traditionelle sozialdemokratische blog insgesamt einfach geschwächt ist
gibt es auch ein paar ausreißer in spanien ist es ja relativ gut gelaufen ist aber ein sehr nationale gründe weil die regierung dort,
ganz gut performt aber insgesamt hat man halt gesehen dass ich eben auch dieser klassische konservativ sozialdemokratische block den man ja
in gewisser hinsicht in den letzten dreißig jahren mehr oder weniger überall auf die ein oder andere art und weise gehabt hat und dass die beiden dann auch letzten endes,
immer unter sich ausgemacht haben wo jetzt gerade der schwerpunkt liegt dass der jetzt auch im eu-parlament zusammen gefallen ist und das ist eben dann keine klare linie gab werde nun zum beispiel die kommission.
Führen soll.
Ähm und das das sehen wir überall in großbritannien wir haben vor kurzem zu dieser lage bei den konservativen und leibe gesprochen habe es ist ähnlich in deutschland oder in frankreich also das bedeutet dann es gab dann ein zusammenschluss,
die drei.
Übrig gebliebene handwerks große fraktionen also die europäischen volksparteien die sozialdemokraten und die liberalen die haben dann ein kompromiss gefunden äh ursula von der leyen aus kommissionspräsidenten zu nominieren
das war aus meiner sicht für demokratien der eu schade weil,
sie war keine spitzenkandidatin für irgendeine fraktion also ein an den tagen nach der europawahl die konservativen haben einfach so gesagt okay also wir wollen manfred weber also unser spitzenkandidat nicht mehr ähm.
Also sie war ja überhaupt gar kein kandidat.
Genau sie war nirgendwo also es war eine komplette überraschung ähm sie war,
also von der leyen war für die konservativen nassen aus zentralen und osteuropa,
akzeptabel weil sie hat nie vorher was zum thema in äh in polen und ungarn die sarah.
Im gegensatz zum thema mainz.
Ja genau so timmermans wäre eine alternative und weiher für deutschland eine alternative weil der der steht für etwas und spitzenkandidat von den sozialdemokraten ähm.
Also und macron mag diese ganze situation die ganze prozedere mit spitzenkandidaten überhaupt nicht also der war dann auch
mehr oder weniger für von der leyen also das war so eine typische
hinter verschlossenen türen de ähm was so oft in der geschichte in der eu stattfand,
aber am ende niemandem ist folgendes damit vollkommen zufrieden die grünen haben dagegen gestimmt haben so gesagt moment mal so wir waren bereit in einen notfall manfred weber zu unterstützen weil er hatte zumindest eine,
eine gewisse also wie sagt man das auf deutsch das.
Da hatte eine gewisse unterstützung von seiner partei also legitimität und aber aber aber von der leyen überhaupt nicht und was von der leyen in sachen klimaschutz politik gesagt hatte
das war für die grünen einfach auch nicht genug also die grünen und die linken äh so um die deutsche partei die linken also die europäischen linken,
dagegen gestimmt einige populisten haben auch dagegen gestimmt
aber dann es gab da so ein breites bündnis mitte des politischen spektrums um um von der leyen zu unterstützen,
sie ist weil sie kommuniziert ein bisschen besser aus jung,
sie ist vielleicht ein bisschen moderne ein bisschen offener als juncker aber.
Zumindest gibt's keine große begeisterung von von von der leyen und von dieser nominierung prozedere sachen brexit sie wird auch fast gar nichts ändern also die linie bleibt es.
Ja ja ich meine es kann kann für sie natürlich auch ein vorteil sein dass sie da als ungeschriebenes blatt reingeht und so als.
Aber wir wissen nicht wofür sie richtig steht also wofür will sie,
am ende doch richtig kämpfen das wissen wir nicht also es wird aus meiner sicht ein risiko versus kommission also und vielleicht brauchen wir etwas ein bisschen radikaler ist gerade.
Na ja aber ich meine es diese ganze debatte mit ob denn das jetzt so so demokratisch gewesen ist klar man jetzt ist wieder was ausgehandelt worden aber in gewisser hinsicht war ja auch der rat dazu gezwungen weil eben das parlament sich nun mal schlecht auf nichts hat einigen können.
Ja aber das ding war das war schnell und gut gespielt
auf der seite der mitgliedschaft in der eu weil mir ein bisschen mehr zeit vielleicht könnte das europäische parlament eine einigung finden aber dann die haben diese dieses gipfels dauerte ein tag länger als geplant weil die mitgliedstaaten die wussten okay wenn wir eine einigung finden also das wir haben dann eine chance dass.
Ging das europäische parlament dann durchzusetzen und es war auch ein fehler schon ende letztes jahr dass die
die europäische konservativen die haben weber statt alexander unterstützt weber war's kandidat schwach also es war,
es gab diversen fehlen auf diversen ebenen da es waren die fehlen waren nicht nur im europäischen parlament ähm und es war eigentlich gesehen besonders von macron es war eigentlich gesehen klug gespielt.
Ja na ja gut jetzt muss man damit quasi leben.
Grundsätzlich kann man aber sagen du hast ja auch schon gesagt dass halt die position und die grundhaltung der eu zum brexit sich eigentlich nicht groß ändern,
niemand diskutiert davon irgendwas wieder auf zu dröseln niemand will irgendwas neu verhandeln und es ist ja auch immer noch paar nee im im auftrage für die eu unterwegs und wird diese linie wahrscheinlich auch knallhart
durchziehen wobei noch bei.
Wahlen sind und bevor wir auf boris johnson kommen wollte ich nochmal in der jüngsten zeit gab es ja dann in auch noch ein paar parlaments nach wahl das ist ja auch so eine eigenschaft in großbritannien dass wenn jetzt ein.
Abgeordneter stirbt oder ich glaube in einem fall gab es eine verurteilung oder also.
Genau in den beiden fällen sogar.
Es ist nicht auch noch einer gestorben.
Ne das war schon im frühling also.
Genau also im im ganzen jahr gab es.
Aber es gab es zwei in den in den letzten monaten
wo in peters und in breaking bad ja so in das ist schwierig für mich das auf deutsch zu beschreiben die die abgeordnete hat eine über eine
wie soll man das fein sie war.
Geschwindigkeit vertretung und.
Wo sie so sehr darüber gelogen und musste dann zurücktreten und in den anderen fall.
In der konservative abgeordnete der hatte in seinem,
so wie er sein büro organisiert er hatte so eine finanzielle skandal in in in,
in seiner ausgaben für seine seine büro organisation also in diese beiden fällen war's dann nötig diese,
actions sowohl zu organisieren die waren,
sehr interessant muss man sagen in petra vorher das war ein sitz mit einem labor abgeordnete laber hat dann eine neue kandidatin gefunden und laber hat dann erneut da gewonnen,
warum,
peter liegt nur eine stunde mit dem zug von london entfernt und die haben die ganze eigentlich wissen von der partei aus london sind appetit gegangen um so ein ground so machen also die haben eine echte erfolgreiche kampagne
da ausgeführt in peters und dann leider hat dann,
trotz eine gute kampagne der brexit partei da gewonnen also laber hat das mit so etwa dreißig prozent
dahinter war brexit partei und dann die konservativen also die brexit lage war so gesplittert zwischen brexit party in concert die konservativen und die konnte dann
deutlich gewinnen.
Daniel hier das ist im im so in den in der mitte von ja also da ist breaking den hauptstadt also von dieser dieses wahlkreis.
Das ist so seo ral keine industrie da eine so eine,
also so markt statt so da in.
Da gewann vorher die konservativen,
und diese konservative abgeordnete musste dann zurücktreten aber der tat dann wieder obwohl er so zurücktreten musste also das war eine katastrophale entscheidungen konservativen und dann die liberalen haben daran gewonnen.
Die liberalen hatten diese sitzt schon vorher schon gewonnen von jahrzehnt also die haben da lokal vor ort äh eine gute organisation und zwar anderen parteien die grünen und die realistischen nationalisten also,
die haben dann
die diese kandidaten sind so zurückgetreten die haben so gesagt wir kandidieren hier nicht wie geben die liberalen so freie fahrt um hier sich gegen die konservativen und die brexit partei,
zu gewinnen es gab so sonntag ab so eine art so,
und dann es gab eine mehrheit von tausend stimmen sorry für die für die liberalen
aber die brexit partei herta viertausend stimmen gekriegt also wenn diese viertausend stimmen gingen an die
an die konservativen wer es noch ein gewinn für die konservativen also es war dann da sehr interessant aber wenn man sieht in peter,
wenn man vor ort gut organisiert ist und wenn die parteien miteinander kooperieren,
da gibt's,
noch hoffen eine hoffnung war für die vögel label eine katastrophe also da lagen die auf den
fünften rein oder so die harten
so kann nur knapp über tausend stimmen gekriegt also weil laber so warum wählt man da laber dort also die ganze leute haben dann die liberalen unterstützt und die ganze brexit leute entweder brexit party concept.
Ja das wird dann war wenn wir über die gegebenenfalls anstehenden neuwahlen diskutieren nochmal ganz interessant werden wir hatten ja schon mehrfach erwähnt dass mehrheits wahlsystem in england ist ein generelles problem.
Könnt ihr jetzt richtig allen um die ohren fliegen mit diesen neuen verteilung und diesen neuen anteilen die halt die parteien bekommen weil im wesentlichen alles so.
Potenziell alles auf auf dem selben level ist also alle haben irgendwie so 'ne chance zwischen fünfzehn und fünfundzwanzig,
prozent zu erreichen und
ich hab so den eindruck so wahlen könnten demnächst ein richtiges würfel spiel werde,
und wenn sowas passiert müsse manchmal auch den letzten noch,
werden dass das vielleicht gar nicht so eine gute idee ist.
Die wirtschaftliche situation ist ja auch nicht ganz uninteressant weil diese ganze.
Vorbereitung oder nicht vorbereitung auf ein brexit insbesondere mit dieser nudel
option also einfach herauszufinden fallen ohne einen zukünftigen vertrag zu haben erschüttert natürlich in zunehmenden maße investitionen die.
Ich weiß ich wie weit sie abgesunken sind aber erheblich da sind milliarden von pfund die nicht investiert werden.
Es hat natürlich auch eine,
auswirkungen generell auf die planung der ganzen unternehmen und gerade in langfristigen branchen wie der automobilbranche.
Merkt man jetzt schon in zunehmenden maße die auswirkungen die japaner hatten ja eigentlich von anfang an gesagt und die haben da so ein paar werke glaube ich in ok.
Ich habe schon angedeutet dass die zum beispiel geht wir wissen ja schon das wird schon geschlossen werden.
Genau und im prinzip haben sie auch gesagt wenn brexit dann halt wirklich kommt dann da sind wir einfach mal komplett weg weil dann gibt es für uns einfach gar keinen grund,
wobei jetzt gerade im falle der japaner ist natürlich jetzt auch noch diese neue bewegung gibt das ja auch das,
handelsabkommen mit der eu lustigerweise ja abgeschlossen ist und jetzt ein eine person auch mit japan existiert so dass im prinzip die japaner ja jetzt auch in japan produzieren können und den europäischen markt beliefern können,
hat man natürlich immer noch shipping und diesen ganzen aufwand.
Oder oder die produzieren stattdessen in der slowakei oder oder in frankreich und johannes in der eu.
Ja gut das hätten sie ja schon immer tun können haben sie aber nicht nur das ist meine frage ist jetzt.
Wie wie sehr spielt das wirklich in der öffentlichkeit eine rolle wird es wahrgenommen das ist halt immer so ein bisschen so eine seiten diskussion habe ich.
Das war nicht wirklich wahrgenommen weil es gibt diversen statistiken also arbeitslosigkeit in großbritannien zum beispiel ist noch gering,
also die qualität von von dieser arbeitsplätzen oder oder inwiefern gute jobs noch zur verfügung sind,
das ist eine andere frage aber wenn man sagt ok es gibt wirtschaftlichen probleme in großbritannien dann antworte die britische regierung nur nein also wir haben äh sehr geringe arbeitslosigkeit na also was du gerade gesagt hat,
das stimmt aber wir haben der idee jetzige situation also alle warten zurzeit es ist alles wir wissen ja nicht wie es ausgehen kann,
die regierung nimmt die diese modelle planungen
kann man nicht so ernst machen weil es wie es in ihr zu siebzig tagen vor dem austritt also das dauert so jahren um genug zollbeamten zu rekrutieren zum beispiel so was bedeutet das.
Obwohl ein no deal brexit so offiziell droht.
Niemand glaubt so hundertprozentig daran,
und man hat noch die hoffnung dass die die abgeordneten britische unterhaus können diese ganze situation dann einfach noch stoppen so was bedeutet das und wo der wirtschaftliche lage
relativ ernsthaft ist es gibt.
Keine echte diskussion darüber was sobald man sowas sagt dann kommt von der regierung einfach mal ja bekannt oder man sieht hier keine brexit also.
Es gibt keine keine faire und komplette und richtige debatte also der wirtschaftslage gerade.
Großbritannien ist immer noch nicht noch nicht in in einer resolution also sobald wirtschaftswachstum geht runter dann das wäre.
Das dann startete dann vielleicht eine bessere diskussion.
Aber das letzte quasi meine rezession ist die definition einer rezession ist zwei quartale hintereinander.
Gab ein quartal.
Genau und ein quartal ist jetzt die wirtschaftliche leistung erstmalig zurück.
Und dem britischen pfund ist auf den niedrigsten stand gegenüber den dollar seit ein jahrzehnt
also tourismus zahlen in großbritannien gehen zurück also das ist eine ehre so die in dem fund ist so billig wie ein jahrzehnten noch nie aber die touristen gehen nicht mehr großbritannien also ja also.
Sehen wir mal aber aber aber zur zeit ich finde die debatte so sehr,
so auf wespenstich gerichtet also nicht auf die probleme des landes also das das die blicken nach innen.
Statt einfach mal so sagen okay wir haben diese reihe von von schwierigkeiten,
dann würden wir uns seriös mit mit der wirtschaftliche lage beschäftigt.
Das mit dem hund ich meine das ist die frage wie wie das eigentlich war genommen wird also was ist denn da,
das ding meine dass das pfund schwach wird ist ja gewisser hinsicht auch erstmal vorteil.
Ich könnte es ein vorteil sein aber das ding ist natürlich also für für exporte industrien wäre es wenn es dann ein vorteil aber ein problem ist dann wenn soll kontrollen.
Kommen dann nach ein nudel brexit also dann man verliert dann diese ganze möglichen vorteile ähm also es ist.
Es ist nicht einfach.
Ein euro.
Sind wir gerade glaube ich oder null neun grade oh mann ich habe ja da vor vier jahren gelebt und da muss ich irgendwie ein euro fünfzig bis sechzig fast äh ausgeben.
Ja und schon vor zwei drei jahren war es noch eins zwanzig oder eins fünfundzwanzig.
Aber warum kommen denn die touristen da nicht wenn es eigentlich so billig ist.
Zwei gründen.
Großbritannien ist nicht in den schengenraum das bedeutet dass man braucht einen anzug einen zusätzlichen visum für großbritannien wenn man kommt von außerhalb der eu
also ein ein ein tourist aus indien oder oder china braucht an zusätzliches visum das ist echt schwierig und treue zu kriegen und es wird immer schwieriger zu kriegen
das bedeutet dass leute aus dieser länder kommen ja nicht und man hat vielleicht den eindruck dass großbritannien kein,
freundliches oder weltoffenes an ist gerade ähm also das sind die für richtungen es gab auch.
Wir können es nicht bestätigen aber es gab auch den der chef von uns von der britischen auto firmen,
das deutsche gesagt niemandem deutschland will ein deutsches auto kaufen gerade nicht weil es kann nicht wann ist ein anständiges auto ist sondern man will das ist nicht mehr so cool.
Da ist was dran ja.
Ja also mit der jetzigen ruf gut für tanz ist das eine abschreckung wir wissen ja nicht das ist aber das ist ein anderes tiere.
Ist auf jeden fall nicht hilfreich.
Ja genau ja ja ja ja ja genau so könnt ihr das mal sagen.
So jetzt ist also theresa may zurückgetreten beziehungsweise sie hat am vierundzwanzigsten mai nach den wahlen angekündigt dass sie zurücktreten wird das war dann im,
na ja nee das war dann sozusagen dass sie.
Ist das parteichef ein paar wochen danach zurückgetreten und dann letztendlich aus premierminister so gedreht am dreiundzwanzigsten parteichef,
endgültig am dreiundzwanzigsten juli und als premierminister am vierundzwanzigsten juli also das dauert eine weile um um nachfolge zu finden wegen dieser,
parteiinterne urwald prozedere bei den bei den konservativen die haben das haben die in so ein zwei etappen gemacht,
zuerst müssen die abgeordneten entschieden welche sind dann die letzten zwei kandidaten und diese zwei kandidaten gehen in sowieso den,
mitglieder in einer so parteiinterne,
briefwahl so eine urwahl unter die parteimitglieder es gab insgesamt zehn kandidatin am anfang.
Und die die die in die letzte runde gegangen sind sind dann boris johnson und und und jeremy hand.
Hallo dann mit so etwas wie ein drittel der abgegebenen stimmen,
hatte dann boris johnson sich dann durchgesetzt,
am vierundzwanzigsten juli dann parteichef geworden also das ist gut zusammengefasst die die situation.
Aber das war war ein ganz interessanter prozess und ich glaube da muss man auch mal wieder ein bisschen was verstehen also die premierministerin tritt zurück man will ja jetzt,
in deutschland erwarten ja okay gut dann neue kanzler kanzlerin müsste gewählt werden macht halt das parlament so ist aber hier irgendwie erstmal nicht so sondern die partei,
wählt sich 'nen neuen vorsitzenden was ja in deutschland für das parlament vorkommen unerheblich ist in gewisser hinsicht und nachdem das dann stattgefunden hat ist diese person automatisch premierminister.
So
Ja nein also es gibt keine und es gibt nicht so kompletten regeln,
für sowas in großbritannien also die königin muss der oder die person einladen,
um eine regierung zu bilden wenn die köln diese person muss die höchste chance haben.
Ein mehrheit in dem britischen unterhaus zu haben das bedeutet dass so ein votum muss nicht unbedingt stattfinden
also das ist jetzt das war die überlegung in den ersten tagen nach johnson s
so machtübernahme leitet germany coman ein misstrauensvotum gegen ihm ein um zu prüfen hat er noch genug unterstützung und äh die konservative abgeordneten,
kommen.
Da kommen wir da da kommen wir gleich.
Kommen hat sich zuerst entschieden dass es nicht zu tun also das bedeutet es ist nicht automatisch,
also die frage wäre dann findet so eine wo ein votum jetzt im herbst statt weil seid johnson im arm ist.
Die konservativen follower haben schon zwei abgeordneten aus der fraktion verloren,
diese nachwahl in die haben das dann verloren also es ging dann eins drunter und es gibt ein eine untersuchung.
Skandal in im gegen eine andere konservative abgeordnete charlie aus doofer dass er ist offiziell,
nicht in der fraktion zurzeit das bedeutet dass zurzeit auf papier,
boris johnson zusammen mit dem irischen die op offiziell eine mehrheit von nur ein einen einzigen sitz im britischen unterhaus das bedeutet dass eine mehrheit ist sehr knapp
aber nach den regeln die kommt die königin muss diese person einleiten der oder die die höchste chance hat
sie über eine mehrheit zu verfügen und,
ist der hat noch eine höhere chance aus sonst noch jemand also lass es dann den grund warum dann
die königin hat dann dann johnson vorgeschlagen.
Ich will doch mal auf diese eigentliche wahl kommen weil ich fand die ganz interessant erstmal wer sich da überhaupt aufgestellt hat also von diesen zehn leuten waren ja die allermeisten hatten mehr oder weniger dieselbe position ja brexit muss stattfinden und das kriegen wir schon wieder alles hin und her
irgendwie alle dasselbe gesagt ansonsten sagt es dann natürlich irgendwie am lautesten und im direkten und das war dann glaube ich für ihn
kaum jemand ein wirklicher konkurrent die einzige person die jetzt besonders auf viel
auch wenn man jetzt nicht den eindruck hatte er hätte viel chancen gehabt aber es war trotzdem ein völlig ganz interessante kurze zeit der debatte war ja.
Der vorher ja auch ein minister amt bekleidet hat für.
Internationaler entwicklung ja ja.
Genau und der ist ja so ein ganz klassischer tory eigentlich so ein so ein intellektuelle wohl gebildet viel gereist,
gesehen irgendwie es zu fuß durch indien marschiert und ich weiß,
also auch in seiner ganzen art und weise fand ich die interviews die er gegeben hat er war der einzige der so ein bisschen so dieses abwägen und dieses jahr und also wo man auch das gefühl hatte da da findet auch ein gedankliche prozess.
Hast du.
Und so ist er dann auch aufgetreten in dieser wahl am anfang gab's da so eine kurze rory mann ja das hat er nicht lange gehalten.
Aber das könnte nie funktionieren weil unter die partei mitglieder der konservativen das kommt ja nicht sehr gut an,
also das ist meine alte traditionelle toren es gibt nicht so viel auto traditionellen touris mehr also,
das wissen wir ja jetzt die hatten
die haben jetzt hundertsechzigtausend mitglieder das können wir bestätigen weil das waren die in die anzahl an anderen so möglichen abgegebenen stimmen,
die die mitglieder der konservativen sind echt.
Richtig so national konservativ geworden also für für diese mitglieder war einfach zu offen oder oder oder zu international also das das
bei den medien gut an da hat das gut kommuniziert er kam in interviews gut rüber aber.
Das hat ihm kaum geholfen weil beide parteimitglieder der konservativen partei das ist nicht was die wollen.
Er war zu liberal oder zu zentral oder zu pragmatisch und da dass das ging dann für ihn.
Ja war einfach mal interessant zu sehen so ah es gibt solche zumindest noch ein
auf der anderen seite war es dann auch sehr interessant wie sein stimmenanteil schwankte weil man hatte so ein bisschen den eindruck dass das johnson lager auch so strategisch im hintergrund so absprachen gemacht.
Weil seine art und weise gegen boris johnson zu debattieren war für johnson ein gefahr,
weil einfach gegen hand oder oder oder,
wieder zu gewinnen ist keine schwierige sache ist auch in aber so
für johnson wäre es am besten entweder oder oder hand in die zweite die zweite runde zu begegnen weil die sind so,
sag ich so klassischen modernen touris also sehr manager mäßig und es war dann für johnson viel einfacher,
gegen gegen hand so debattieren as gegen stewart.
Aber es war ganz interessant dass dieser wahl modus der ja irgendwie auf den ersten blick erstmal,
ganz interessant ist weil es nicht einfach nur so eine reine mehrheits wahl ist sondern eben schritt für schritt immer mit ausscheiden aber trotzdem ist natürlich sehr viel taktieren möglich gerade mit dem ziel am schluss ist es halt nur noch der ein oder andere und ganz andere leute stimmen ab,
gut könnt verkürzen am ende hat es das ergebnis gegeben mit dem jeder gerechnet hat das heißt boris johnson war dann,
der neue chef der torres und dann eben wie du schon erklärt hast dadurch dass quasi die queen dann gesagt hat ok du bist jetzt aber weil ja theoretisch immer noch die mehrheit im parlament habt,
premierminister und deswegen wurde er eingeladen und dann ist das,
war sie per akku durch die queen dann geworden.
Ja genau.
Dann ging's ja relativ,
schnell und er hat dann innerhalb kürzester zeit eine neue regierung vorgestellt was im wesentlichen erstmal mit so einem cleanup stattfand also es glaube ich sozusagen alle leute die irgendwie klar denken können.
Alle in die höchsten ausgetauscht,
der hat alle oder fast alle vorherigen die die für für remain gestimmt haben hat er ausgewechselt das neue finanzminister bis neue außenminister,
die waren auch so zwei gegnern von ihm äh bei der bei der urwahl
ähm teil ist ist innenminister drin also sie ist eine krass hart,
konservative figur also sie war bis vor kurzem offiziell für die todesstrafe zum beispiel.
Und sie wurde ja auch vorher noch aus der regierung aus.
Ja genau wegen einem skandal oh nein auch einen sehr großen und seriösen skandal.
Und das ist für boris johnson völlig.
Das war das war für uns für die konservativen egal,
also die normalen regeln das wenn wenn man merkt dass man korrupt ist dass man muss da draußen bleiben also wer anscheinend,
das hat keinen einfluss mehr auf verse rock kommen kann aber aber positive teil ist vollkommen auf auf johnson s harte brexit kurs,
also das war der der der der wollte ein team so mit ali,
um ihn zu schützen und und das kann auf jeden fall machen.
Und auch die anderen weil das im prinzip alles leute die hier in der popularität nicht das wasser reichen können und sich innerhalb dieser kandidaten kühe ja letztlich genauso positioniert haben und damit eigentlich fest verdrahtet sind mit.
Ja und es ist auch sehr interessant also einige haben schon gekündigt schon vor,
den am dem beginn von von johnson amtszeit gibt so gesagt okay wir treten zurück wie der ehemalige finanzminister hameln oder der ehemaliger justizminister gurke aber dann anderen also.
Und.
Auch ja aber zum beispiel jeremy hand wir wussten der wollte bleiben,
der wollte außenminister bleiben und johnson hat so gesagt ne also ich ich der war bereit,
den posten der von verteidigungsminister an an hand zu geben und dann seid ihr sorry aber dass das reicht mir nicht dann lieber gar nichts
also was bedeutet das johnson hat jetzt.
Ganz ganz viele sehr sehr harte gegner auf die sogenannten bändchen die eine reihe von,
hinterbänkler die guten kontakten haben und auch fähige abgeordneten sind leute wie der ehemalige bundesminister hameln der ehemalige finanzminister hund vielleicht vielleicht sogar auch may also was bedeutet das.
S und die man hat von diesen menschen in den letzten wochen gar nichts gehört
aber die frage ist wenn ein votum dann stattfindet zum thema new brexit wir agieren dann diese ganze ex ministers die die überhaupt nicht mit mit mit johnson,
regieren wollten sowas ist die große frage für die nächsten für die nächsten paar.
Also es macht schon eigentlich den eindruck dass er.
Eine regierung anführt die keine wirkliche parlaments mehrheit hat.
Ja nein also ich wähle zu wissen weil,
wir wissen es gibt es gibt keine mehrheit für ein.
Aber gibt's noch eine mehrheit für eine konservative regierung.
Oder gibt es überhaupt eine mehrheit für eine andere regierung also das ist gerade die große frage weil die in eine normale situation,
wäre der oppositions chef eine gute alternative als premierminister so so jemand könnte dann ein eine alternative regierung vielleicht kunden aber natürlich niemand will unbedingt mit,
jeremy kurven regieren es gibt einige unabhängige abgeordnete die offiziell zu den opposition gehören,
aber tendenziell recht sind wieso wir hermann seine euro unabhängige abgeordnete aus nordirland zum beispiel also wäre sylvie herum und je bereit.
Eine eine regierung von jeremy kurven zu unterstützen ehe nicht und es geht es gäbe natürlich eine lösung wäre so eine wie wir menschen seine sonne
einheits regierung oder so aus diversen parteien so eine übergangs regierung.
Aber sowas wäre nur möglich mit einer kooperation zwischen eine große gruppe konservativen runter eine große gruppe laber abgeordneten,
und das schließt jeremy kurbeln auch geradeaus weil der will premierminister werden und sagen ok
ich hab die höchste chance premierminister zu werden also und dann leute denken jetzt gerade okay wir geben ihm dann mehr oder weniger dann die chance,
zu versuchen,
eine regierung zu bilden was bedeutet es an sehr schwierig also es ist es ist einfach ein mehrheit gegen ein no deal zuwenden als ein mehrheit gegen johnson.
Aber dann kommt das eu dann wieder ins spiel also wenn das britische unterhaus stimmt mal wieder ein gesetz ab wir sind gegen ein nudel und wir wollen noch eine verlängerung.
Ist bruste bereit zu sein ja klar so wir geben euch noch mehr zeit im moment mal so der rat fresse denn hans also gesagt,
schon im frühling,
wenn mal wieder im oktober großbritannien okay wir brauchen einfach mehr zeit weil.
Wir haben sonst keine andere lösungen wie wäre dann die reaktion auf der brüssel seid also das bedeutet es,
wie diese ganze situation dann ausgeht ist dann see schwierig was wir zumindest.
Ding wir gehen davon aus dass wir sind noch in der sommerpause.
Jetzt in zwei wochen abend am dritten september tag das britische unterhaus mal wieder und wir gehen davon aus dass die das label,
leite dann mal wieder ein misstrauensvotum ein.
Und an wie hoch sind dann die chancen dass diese so ein votum erfolgreich sein könnte,
vielleicht sechs ich so vierzig oder siebzig dreißig weil so viele so viele abgeordnete haben eins von von ideal also aber die chancen dass johnson so ein misstrauensvotum dann überleben könnte.
Sind noch relativ hoch was sind dann die nächste schritt also das bedeutet das.
Alle reden über ein misstrauensvotum gerade und wann könnte sowas dann stattfinden also das ist die große debatte jetzt gerade.
Da wollte ich gleich nochmal ein bisschen genauer drauf eingehen aber lass mich vorher nochmal kurz diese dieses team nochmal genauer anschauen
weil da gibt's ja auch noch eine andere interessante person
zwar nicht in einem minister amt aber als spezial berater oder wie das heißt ist ja dominik comics auch in diese regierung oder zumindest in dieses was ich aber dann offiziell teil der regierung ist.
Berater aber das nicht offiziell teil der regierung.
Aber er ist auf jeden fall teil dieses systems was johnson jetzt hier macht dominik comics war der chef der lief eu kampagne und ist.
Eine ganz spezielle persönlichkeit sehr intelligenter mensch der.
Oder eine sehr zielorientiert mensch.
Und als person innerhalb der der politische system eine sehr ungewöhnliche menschen weil der ist,
sehr unfreundlich desto silo orientiert es hart und der sobald ein ziel gesetzt hat,
der hält nicht bis er dieses dieses ziel erreicht hatte,
und das ist was so anders ist bei ihm das nicht wie die meisten politische berater die bereit sind okay wir machen hier kompromiss damit der politiker sich wohlfühlt das ist eine sehr unwohl persönlichkeit,
irgendwie und das ist.
Dann dass das das im johnson mal wieder diese sowohl lieb team sowie du verbrannt hat,
jetzt intendant street das ist fast die leute dann zu viel angst macht.
Aber comics hat auch
krass viele gegner weil der ist so eine unbequeme persönlichkeit und weil es so viele gegner hat das ist nicht immer einfach für ihn
leute zu zu überzeugen es heißt gerade also ein gegengewicht gegen ihn intendant street gerade den lister heißt der ehemalige
so berater von johnson johnson london burgermeister war.
Und da ist eine etwas pragmatische typ also es gibt so ganz viele macht spannungen innerhalb von johnson team in nintendo street aber man muss,
also um und und muss man muss auch sagen comics ist kein demokrat.
Also der will unbedingt raus aus der eu am einunddreißigsten oktober und er sieht das großbritannien mehrheit nicht dafür gestimmt hat und kein preis ist für ihn zu hoch,
der wäre auch bereit einfach mal raus aus der eu zu stürzen ohne einen plan um einfach mal das zu tun
und es sieht das auch als etwas vielleicht als etwas positives ja die briten die die faulen briten
die können von sowas lernen das leben das leben ist für die briten so einfach hat er vorher angedeutet der ist so eine
so so eine mark liberale dass das gegen eine starke staat also das ist was was was ihm so stark antreibt.
Ja und ich versuche mir nämlich gerade so ein bisschen diese eigentlichen frage die.
Wo ich auch gemerkt hab wenn ich wenn ich so mit anderen leuten in deutschland darüber die mich fragen so brexit
wie siehst du denn das und warum gehen sie überhaupt alle so ab und wir haben ja auch schon am anfang sehr viel drüber gesprochen und ich schau mir dann so leute wie diesen dominik comics an also der hat ja so ein bisschen so diese diese diese,
sichtweise der staat ist zu groß so aufgeblasen
public service ist irgendwie alles mist weil die kommen nicht voran da werden zu viele kompromisse beschlossen dass es irgendwie alles zu zu träge zu schwerfällig und ich glaube er sieht so ein bisschen die welt mit dieser brille mit
wenn man heutzutage quasi dominant sein will und das ist ja auch immer so dieses wiederkehrende diese wiederkehrende vision so,
okay also singular so als super moderner körper
der so hongkong style irgendwie einfach alle regeln beiseite lässt und das ganze wieder auf so eine neue art und weise wirtschaftlich dominiert
vielleicht mehr mit k i und internet und äh ja so so auf dieser gedanken ebene scheint er sicher zu bewegen,
und das eben dann auch gleichzeitig mit der akzeptanz des politik einer verbrannten erde
im prinzip sagt so ja dann seid ihr mal zwanzig jahre arm ich ja nicht aber es ist ja alles wertvoll für ein höheres ziel,
der andere anderes bin.
Gehört habe der sozusagen diesen ganzen projekt unterstellt wird es so dieses diese denke eines desaster kapitel ist so nach dem motto naja
ist ja nicht so schlimm wenn jetzt mal alles vor die hunde geht
dann können die leute die viel geld haben danach schön viel land kaufen und stehen viele fabrik,
rum mit dem man später vielleicht mal wieder was anfangen kann passt doch alles.
Ist das jetzt schon ein bisschen zu viel verschwörungstheorie oder haben wir es einfach hier mit diesem live-video projekt und im prinzip jetzt auch mit dieser regierung
mit so 'ner gruppe zu tun der wirklich alles egal ist und die sozusagen nur noch für so ein
sehr eingeschränkt des ziel einer kleinen elite kämpft unter der der flagge des populismus oder ist das dann auch schon wieder zu übertrieben.
Es gibt einige menschen die unbedingt diese linie unterstützen aber die sind nicht ein mehrheit,
der liebe wähler es gibt viele leute die diese glaube haben
um johnson und beide konservative partei aber wenn alles dann schief geht um es wirtschaftlich problematisch für großbritannien wird kurzfristig dann ist die regierung die chirurg.
Dass das dann die eu show,
weil nudel war nie unser plan und es war wegen diese böse böse europäer dann müssen wir dann trotz unser versuche dann
noch doch noch notinsel doch machen also was das ist die die linie mehrheitlich.
Brexit villa.
Genau gegen diese desaster kapitel lesen also die sind leute die wollen mehr sicherheit besseren jobs die sind so.
Sie wollen so die alte guten wirtschaftlichen zeiten zurück,
also die wollen mehr sicherheit nicht weniger sicherheit also und das war immer dieses kompromiss,
diese zwischen dieser.
Diese so take control ähm diese voll in großbritannien zurück zu den fünfziger aus großbritannien noch,
manufaktur industrie hatte auf eine seite,
und auf der anderen seite diese sehr so macht mag liberale
hassen nicht zusammen aber.
Dem weg diese diese lücke sie überbrücken
ist einfach mal ah ja wir wollten keine deal ne das war nie unsere gedanke die waren die böse europäer die dass du uns getan hatten die waren dann shot und das ist an dem das worum es uns kurzfristig wirtschaftlich schlecht geht,
also das ist so wie die das dann da dann argumentieren es ist auch ein problem es ist eben menschlich dass man.
Nicht akzeptieren kann dass man ein fehler gemacht hat.
Viele von den brexit befürwortern die die grunde wohnen die am anfang für einen brexit waren.
Diese kunde gibt es ja nicht mehr na diese möglichen wirtschaftswachstum nach dem brexit mehr geld für die gesundheitswesen wir wissen jetzt es stimmt nicht also wir haben.
Leute die ein bisschen daran gedacht haben wussten schon im voraus dass ich sowas nicht gibt aber es ist jetzt klar es gibt die man redet nicht mehr über die positiven aspekt,
brexits sondern man muss es machen wenn man das machen muss also weil eine mehrheit der bürger dafür gestimmt haben niemanden haben für eine nudel brexit gestimmt
also die haben vor zweitausendsechzehn von für wie isis dealen history geredet
ja also es ist jetzt genau den gegenteil also aber jetzt ist es die haben dafür gewählt in zweitausendsechzehn,
bedeutet dass du jeden preis man muss es jetzt heutzutage noch machen und das ist ein altes,
politiker einfacher so ein argument zu machen also einfach mal so sein im moment arbeite wir haben hier einen fehler gemacht die vorteile des brexit gibt es ja nicht wir müssen jetzt nachdenken,
also das ist schwierig also abgeordnete so so so so agieren einfach mal zu sagen im moment mal das war ein katastrophales fehler das ist hart für viele politiker sowas werkzeug tieren oder sowas zu sagen.
Auch viele bürger.
Auch für die bürger ja aber und die burger niemand will akzeptieren auch moment mal also diese lügen von zweitausendsechszehn ja also,
das waren ja lügen,
ja niemand will also sorgt tieren dass man man hat auf falschen prämisse so eine entscheidung getroffen das ist dann sehr sehr schwierig man man braucht zeit
und man braucht eine ähnliche und breite und tiefe diskussion um
zu verstehen auch im moment mal wir haben hier ein fehler getan also einfach mal diese überlegung gibt's auf allen ebenen.
Was ist denn jetzt die offizielle politik von boris johnson auf der einen seite also was sagt er was er will.
Was ist deine vermutung was dir was die eigentliche kalkulation ist weil man hat ja ich hatte so 'n bisschen den eindruck auch.
Dass auch dieser wahn.
Vielleicht bringen könnte sondern eigentlich mehr von dem gedanken dass,
wenn das alles nichts wird und die kacke richtig am dampfen ist das
dass er so derjenige ist der einfach mit seinem populismus ein nigel farage noch in den schatten stellen kann und in irgendeiner form die fälle die langsam davon schwimmen für die stories nochmal aus dem see fischen.
Die offizielle linie vom johnson ist.
Dieses ab austrittsabkommen müssen wir radikal ändern und dieses austrittsabkommen kann den not irischen bug stop nicht mehr.
In hanau.
Was natürlich mit der eu nicht zu machen.
Genau und weil.
So erst eine kleine erinnerung was ist diese not irischen backstube höchstes priorität ist für die eu,
und für irland dass es keine harte grenze in irland gibt was passiert wenn es gibt diverse produkt standard ne und soweit gras stand da zum beispiel auf eine seite als auf der anderen seite wie kontrolliert man dann sowas,
in erster linie soll es dann technischen lösungen geben damit es an der grenze keine kontrollen gibt.
Also das ist die vorstellung der des parlaments na.
Und auch die eu sagt ja wir lassen das so rein wir glauben einfach nicht daran das bedeutet das wir brauchen dieses bug stoppen.
Das im falle dass diese technische lösungen nicht gebt großbritannien muss dann.
Während eine bestimmte periode in eine zone union mit der eu dann bleiben und ganz großbritannien,
warum ganz großbritannien weil die not irischen die akzeptieren keine soll kontrollen auf die fairen zwischen nordirland und den rest von großbritannien.
Was wahrscheinlich sogar noch das realistisch so wäre ne ja.
Das wäre die beste lösung also das bedeutet das john johnson begründet jetzt wir brauchen ein austritt aus abkommen,
ohne diesen bug stop weil wir akzeptieren kein sozialunion mit der eu mittelfristig das ist was er gerade sagt,
was für optionen härte dann.
Entweder man geht zurück zu den ursprünglichen bikestore also und soll union nur für nun irland und dann soll kontrollen auf den fairen das bedeutet nur springt aus der regierung und er hat dann deutlich keine mehrheit mehr fertig,
man will da nennt mann mann ach einfach ein nudel brexit.
Okay also das droht dann schon einmal mal interessieren oktober oder man hofft dass die eu bereit wäre seine position so ändern,
und man man schließt irgendeinen anderen abkommen bis den einunddreißigsten oktober ab also das geht.
Auf keinen fall weil die eu steht hundert prozent hinte hinter irland ein nudel
das versucht dann die das das britische unterhaus schon zu stoppen und zurück so ein nordirakischen ein bike nur für nordirland dann ist dann boris johnson das eigene regierung schon am ende.
Also die sind die drei optionen praktisch also fast johnson will ein austrittsabkommen,
ohne den bak stop geht nicht also und das wissen wir ja so die.
Das muss ja doch selber auch wissen.
Ja nein also das hat er hauptsächlich akzeptiert aber der versucht das zu kommunizieren ja ich kam zu den europäer mit einem ernsthaft ein angebot und die haben das abgelehnt also die eu ist darin dann schon.
Ja genau es geht im wesentlichen darum hier ein plan zu starten und nicht nicht irgendeine politik umzusetzen.
Ja genauso das ist keine dann das bedeutet das wir alle die das ein bisschen analysiert haben haben sie gesehen das kann nicht funktionieren also das geht nicht.
Also was könnte dann doch funktionieren das bedeutet das boot bedeutet dann es tot an ein und auswahl entweder.
Johnson geht zurück zu den ursprüngen variante die springt aus der regierung oder später oder unterstützt johnson nicht mehr.
Man muss dann ein unter auswahl organisieren johnson hätte dann keine mehrheit mehr oder.
Laber leitet ein misstrauensvotum ein und johnson versteht dass es dieses gefahr gibt er wäre bereit dieses misstrauensvotum schon sogar zu verlieren.
Weil.
Er denkt ihr könnte dann in unterhaus wahl dann gewinnen weil er gewinne dann die ganze.
Partei wählen dann zurück ich war für brexit es waren die börse oppositionsparteien die das gestoppt haben.
Und die eu also alle anderen sind schuld ich bin der der einzige ernsthafte brexit ich lade verarsche ein vielleicht sogar vize parteichef der konservativen zu werden oder ich gebe ihnen einen abend als minister.
Wir vereinen die pro brexit w l a hinter uns.
Wir gewinnen fünfunddreißig prozent angeben stimmen und wir gewinnen sogar in unterhaus war oder noch eine krasse krasse variante.
Es dauert ja ein bisschen bis man ein wahl in großbritannien organisieren könnte,
ein misstrauensvotum findet an diesem wochenende an die an die woche beginnt am dritten september statt,
dann gibt's noch genug seite an und zwar am vierundzwanzigsten oktober zu organisieren also knapp eine woche vor dem austritt wenn man das,
nur eine woche irgendwie verzögert ja dieses misstrauensvotum gelingt erst in der woche,
ab dem zehnten september
dann könnte ein und haus war erst am einunddreißigsten oktober stattfinden also an dem brexit tag selbst was bedeutet das ist droht dann schon ein nudel brexit an dem gleichen tag wie den wieder unterhaus war also lass dich genau,
der dominik,
taktik also lass mal mit einem kleinen eine kleine verzögerung lass dann mal die großbritanniens aus der eu aus jura stürzen wären ein und haus-maus kampagne,
also aus meiner sicht das geht ja nicht und das britische unterhaus wäre in einem notfall situation sowas dann zu stoppen.
Also das sind dann,
das ist da dann das jetzt gespielt also wir wissen dass johnson macht schon die vorbereitung für vorbereitungen für ein unterhaus war.
Die sammeln schon spenden für ein so ein unterhaus wahl und johnson gings dann einfach dann alle pro brexit wähler hinter den konservativen zu vereinigen,
um dann so ein unterhaus wahl zu gewinnen,
und dann auf der anderen seite also laber hat immer noch keine klare position aber dann ist dann gibt es dann ein versuch dann,
die brexit gegner parteien dann zu vereinigen um zumindest dann damit die die liberalen in grünen gewinnen dann genug sitze ja siebzig achtzig sitze damit und,
labor und konservativen kein mehrheit haben man muss nicht vergessen dass es,
droht das gefahr für die konservativen wähler an den liberalen so verlieren weil ein viertel der nie sogar mehr ein drittel der konservative,
wähler haben für den verbleib bestimmt,
also ist tot dann für die konservativen dass die verlieren diese wähler zu den liberalen,
also das spiel ist dann für johnson.
Volle risiko aber auf der anderen seite der handel mehrheit offiziell von einem sitz.
Praktisch gesehen hatte vielleicht eine mehrheit von vielleicht fünf sitze also das wird auch schmelzen mittelfristig,
einige abgeordneten könnte die fraktion verlassen es gab schon die erste drohung von ein paar pragmatischen wie babe oder oder oder wie also was bedeutet das,
einfach mal diese offizielle plan von form von von johnson kein bikestore mehr ein neues härteres noch härteres brexit zu verhandeln raus aus der eu am einunddreißigsten oktober
die halt nicht es ist entweder der findet ein weg so den nudeln am einunddreißigsten oktober und es findet an unter hausfrau statt also die sind die zwei dinge die stattfinden,
also mit die höchste wahrscheinlichkeit und ich werde noch auf eine unterhaus war.
Weil ich sehe dass es gibt es gibt ein klein klare mehrheit in den britischen und haus,
gegen no deal.
Die stimme die werden dann gegen eine nudel stimmen die gehen dann so zu der eu und die usa tee moment mal so wir verstehen dass ihr seid gegen eine auswahl aber wofür wofür seid ihr denn.
Und dann komme man dann vielleicht dann so ein ein nein ein.
Erneut eine runde auswahl mit zuerst eine kleine brexit verlängerung also das ist worauf ich jetzt gerade.
Ja das rennen ist du ja auch mal aushalten ja letztes mal schon dein äh deine diagramm erwähnt eine brexit die du ähm auch weiterhin pflegst das aktuelle berechnet also.
Für die die es nicht mehr erinnern dass es so eine art,
flow für politische entscheidung wie sie den fallen können und da halt alles hier mit einer bestimmten wahrscheinlichkeit gewichtet ist,
kann man am ende halt auch die wahrscheinlichkeit für die daraus resultierenden vorläufigen endergebnis e berechnen da steht derzeit bei dir generell election im august für mit zweiundsiebzig prozent
ganz weit vorne.
Diese situation.
Mit dem mit der konferenz wir hatten das ja schon kurz angesprochen.
Wenn das sozusagen jetzt sofort wenn das parlament eröffnet eingebracht wird wonach sehr vielleicht auch aussieht und.
Die wahl würde nun tatsächlich gegen boris johnson gehen was wäre dann jetzt erstmal die unmittelbare rechtliche konsequenz daraus.
Also diese situation ist mit über den sogenannten fix geregelt,
das bedeutet dass im falle ein misstrauensvotum stattfindet und gelingt,
man hat dann zwei wochen zeit um eine lösung zu finden entweder den jetzigen premierminister.
Ändert irgendwas geht in richtung eine sandstürme brexit zum beispiel und gewinne dann die unterstützung der abgeordneten zurück.
Oder sonst noch jemanden bildet eine rippen so mehrheitsfähig der regierung.
Man hat zwei wochen zeit für sowas wenn das nicht gelingt findet dann automatisch ein unterhaus frau statt und so das ist wie es funktioniert.
Andere variante ist wenn boris johnson selbst ein unterhaus wahl wedel das kann er tun.
Wenn er verfügt über eine zweidrittelmehrheit im britischen unterhaus das bedeutet ich kann sagen ich wähle einen frühen unterhaus war selbst entscheiden ich wäre ein unserer auswahl statt ein verein kompetent aber dafür braucht man dann zwei drittel der abgeordneten,
es gibt zwei kein zwei drittel der abgeordneten die für ein bein.
Neuwahl ohne ein knallharten garantie von von boris johnson das brexit vermeidet also das schließe ich zuerst aus.
Die frage und das ist grade die debatte zwischen joe vorsitzender der vorsitzenden der liberalen und manch anderen,
wie fern will man wissen
wo gibt es ja die mehrheiten.
Es gibt eine mehrheit für irgendeine übergangs regierung zum beispiel vor man dann ein misstrauensvotum einleitet.
Das ist gerade die überlegung wollen wir sicher sein dass es eine mehrheit für eine andere regierung gibt,
vor man ein misstrauensvotum prozedere gegen boris johnson anfangen will also was meine seite aus meiner sicht es wäre sinnvollsten einfach mal zu probieren.
Was wir wissen ist boris jeremy kurbeln will probieren an eine regierung zu bilden wenn das scheitert.
Dann vielleicht hätte dann sonst noch jemand eine chance es gibt die gerüchte das kenne ich klar der alte konservative hinterbänkler könnte sowas vielleicht versuchen oder harry harman eine ehemalige vize parteichef der labour party.
Also und die beiden haben sie gesagt also wir sind bereit sowas machen in eine notfall situation also die haben sich so ein bisschen raus.
Aber wäre das dann nicht gleich auch das politische ende von kurbeln.
Ja und das ist fast die hälfte der content laber abgeordnete noch wollen ja und das ist das größte problem also wenn die.
Es gibt diese riesen spannung innerhalb der partei weil die hälfte der leber abgeordnete vertrauen kommen überhaupt nicht und das bedeutet dass die die,
die denken die okay wir unterstützen kurdin weil kurven ist irgendwie weniger börse als brexit,
und ist anders rum also das habe ich vor ein paar tagen also das hier ist eine eine entscheidung was ist am schlimmsten ein nudel brexit oder eine,
übergangs regierung unter kurve in ein paar monate lang,
zumindest einen und haushalt oder ein zweites referendum so organisieren was ist am schlimmsten aus meiner sicht,
ein brexit ist deutlich schlimmer aus meiner sicht aber,
ich hab so krass harte gegen reaktionen der ist ein rassist der ist antisemiten,
das können wir auf keinen fall akzeptieren das geht ja nicht im moment mal das ist nur wer eine übergangs periode also,
pass auf hier ja so nudel also sobald großbritannien raus ist ja großbritannien ist dann raus muss dann erneut beiträgen also das ist,
der katastrophal also ja ich bin auch kein großes fan von von kurven als person ja aber
ich wäre bereit koblenz unterstützen werden eine übrigens periode nur diese stoppen aber das ist genau das problem gerade
also was ist denn die wenigsten schlimm von von von bonbon von diese beide optionen.
Ich meine diese regierung wäre ja auch nicht lange im amt also.
Genau genau genau das ja einfach mal.
Aber trotzdem aber da kann man ja sehen.
Wird niemand vertrauen kommen weil alle laber abgeordnete der ist für ein brexit und der wilhelm brexit also niemand vertraut ihm auf seine eigene bänken und nun auf die opposition bedenken die konservativen banken.
Also das ist im kern von dieses problem.
Das heißt es könnte durchaus sein.
Dass diese nordkonferenz rot einberufen wird.
In irgendeiner form meint er würde das schaffen ist dann vielleicht aber nicht schafft.
Dann irgendeine andere gruppe ein deal findet der dann auch akzeptiert wird kommen wäre dann automatisch quasi am ende.
Das wäre ein sehr gefährliches spiel aber es
könnte doch gelingen ja hier jeremy also wir geben euch eine mehrheit für ein misstrauensvotum hier leid mal das misstrauensvotum ein ja dann steht dann schaltet dann johnson an dem misstrauensvotum kurven versucht eine regierung zu bilden es scheiterte innerhalb von ein paar tagen oh wir haben hier eine alternative das ist dann die kennen quark oder oder ariane,
da bieten wir eine region wir retten die ganze situation alles innerhalb von zwei wochen schwierig ja also.
Wir sind wir sind in dem territorium dass das irgendwie dass sie alles so ein bisschen so bananen republik mäßig aus ja also
man versucht irgendwas zu retten innerhalb von paar wochen man weiß ja nie droht dann ein nudel brexit wären aneinander eine unterhaus wahlkampagne oder so ja also,
das ist ja unglaublich und es gibt hier keine gute lösungen aber irgendwie dieses idee dass das man muss irgendeinen positiven richtig guten eindruck ja geben dieses ruf ging ja schon verloren für die.
Also aber es wird also theoretisch gibt es so viele möglichkeiten die noch offen sind ja also es wird
echt spannend und sehr schwierig sein in den kommen in den kommenden monaten also,
und es könnte es ist nicht unbegrenzt wie viele wie viele mal eine ein misstrauensvotum meinem mann einladen könnte hier auf meinem jetzigen diagram,
habe ich zurzeit nur ein misstrauensvotum
ich habe heute vormittag getötet okay ist aber ich bin jetzt aus meinem urlaub zurück also was hab ich ja so verpasst.
Wir reden jetzt über ein zweites misstrauensvotum hey also wie funktioniert das denn
man versucht das erste mal es scheitert und johnson bleibt im abend die hinterbänkler dann stimmen dann ein gesetz ab um nudel zu verhindern
johnson tut das einfach nicht ja er geht nicht nach russland zu verhindern also das respektier den unterhaus nicht und man braucht dann ein zweites misstrauensvotum dann in oktober vor dem austritt,
also was für eine antwort.
Okay also mein nächstes diagramm brauche dann zwei misstrauensvotum da drauf wenn das das erste mal nicht gelingt und in einem notfall situation zwei wochen vor dem austritt man muss es dann erneut versuchen.
Also dann die sind die die debatten gerade ist echt verrückt.
Eine neuwahl scheint also jetzt immer wahrscheinlicher zu werden auch wenn wir noch nicht so ganz genau wissen wodurch sie ausgelöst wird aber nur deal droht zwar irgendwie aber.
Man kann eigentlich davon ausgehen dass wodurch auch immer es quasi in so eine automatismus gehen würde.
Du denkst auch der widerstand vom parlament oder von anderen kräften wäre immer groß genug das noch in irgendeiner form zu verhindern.
Heißt ja letzten endes das eigentlich auch nur eine neuwahl das ganze auflösen kann heißt aber dann auch dass die komplette arbeit meeting mit dem wir jetzt in den letzten zwei jahren gearbeitet haben in diesem parlament komplett neu ausgehe würfelt wird.
Wenn man das mal durchspielt und ich hatte das vorhin ja auch schon erwähnt wir haben jetzt ein geschlechtes lava ein geschwächte story haben
die brexit partei mit einem unklaren potenzial an zustimmung das waren jetzt dreißig prozent bei der europawahl aber das ist ja dann auch wieder alles neu gemischt zumal ja das weder verhalten sich eben weil wir alle wissen jetzt kommt wieder mehrheits wahl
wir hatten ja bei dem bei der europawahl tatsächlich,
ein ähnliches wahlverhalten fahren wie auch in deutschland also,
mit anteilen das heißt es ist sehr schwer abzusehen wie die wähler sich ein,
durchaus sein dass auch noch mit gestärkt den liberale demokraten wir in sehr vielen wahlkreisen in england so ein jeder kriegt zwanzig prozent,
szenario haben und dass sie auch schon gesagt ist ja im prinzip wie würfeln weil eine stimme mehr,
kann halt hier bedeuten entweder hart rechts oder irgendwie.
Ja links in dem sinne gibt's ja gar nicht zur auswahl oder irgendein anderes neutrales spektrum so und.
Wow also ich meine das ist ja die am schlechtesten vorhersehbar wahl ever.
Ja aber es gibt info aus drei sehr wichtigen fragen.
Erstens was tut boris johnson in richtung oder was sagt er sucht läden verarsche ein und sagt ok wir bilden hier ein bündnis konservativen plus brexit partei.
Also wie wir vor einigen alle pro brexit stimmen zurzeit man,
johnson ist richtig viel druck von farage also du johnson ist nicht radikal genug ähm also das geht ja nicht wie die brexit partei haben schon die essen
kandidaten gefunden für für wahlkreisen das tun wir ja nicht ja aber das ist so ein bisschen ins spiel also das ist frage nummer eins,
frage nummer zwei ist wie sehe dann die label position aus also ist wäre laber dann bereit in ein unterhaus wahl wahlkampagne ranzugehen mit eine sehr klare,
wenn nicht gegen brexit position zumindest ein für ein zweites referendum position,
wenn ja das könnte alles ein bisschen für die partei dann retten und dann frage drei bis dann.
Wie reagieren oder wie arbeiten die die parteien zusammen,
das bedeutet das findet man dann ein bündnis aus welchen liberalen grünen schottischen nationalisten und politischen nationalisten dass die nicht gegeneinander in bestimmten wahlkreisen kandidieren.
Das bedeutet dass die liberalen kandidieren nicht den briten damit die grünen da gewinnen die grünen kandidieren nicht mehr im breaking bad maschiert damit die liberalen dann gewinnen dass die
der politischen nationalisten kandidieren in die liberalen da nicht damit,
die dann da gewinnen also das bedeutet wenn man findet dann ein allianz zwischen vier kleine kleine parteien also
wäre sowas möglich so die sind die dann die drei fragen johnson bloß verarscht kooperation oder nicht.
Wie sieht die leber die laber position aus und gibt es eine gute kooperation zwischen die beiden parteien oder nicht also dann das bedeutet dass wenn labor position hat,
die können dann bergauf gehen in den meinungsumfrage wenn nicht dann bei runter
wenn boris johnson keine einigung mit verarscht findet es droht dann dass die brexit partei wähler also ihr partei nimmt die die konservativen die wähler dann weg,
und dann das bedeutet dass die liberalen könnte man dann wahlkreis mit fünfundzwanzig prozent dann gewinnen also was bedeutet das man könnte riesengroßen schwanken sehen sehen,
in den meinungsumfrage vor ein unterhaus war aber es drohe für.
Alle parteien vollkommen ein vollkommen katastrophales ergebnis nicht unbedingt für laber laber hat ein kern.
Von hundertfünfzig zweihundert wahlkreisen die richtig sicher sind.
Die wählen ja lebe dort egal was passiert ne.
Bei den konservativen die haben ist doof für die konservativen überall die brexit partei war eine seite und den wahlkreis wie die wahl des wahlkreises von johnson und ja also da sind die sind die liberalen relativ stark
weil auch die diesen wahlkreisen rund um london die so an der kippe waren zwischen liefern also das bedeutet das,
es gibt nicht so viele bomben sicherung wahlkreisen für die konservativen,
und ja und und die liberalen die denken die haben ein bisschen überall eine chance ja also wo die vorher wurde in zweitausendzehn die hatten damals mehr über fünfzig sitzen wo die zweitausendzehn gewonnen haben plus einige in so in zu bewerben.
Muss denn ein premierminister auch ein parlament sitz haben das heißt wenn boris.
Im schwierig der muss entweder im haus im hause kommen sitzen.
Also ich könnte sein dass wenn boris johnson verliert seine eigenen wahlkreis der könnte dann theoretisch im hause flott sitzen nämlich in der sächsische gab es ein premierminister der nur in dem haus saß.
Aber wie kommt ihr da rein.
Weil der kann nominiert werden von die regierung die frage ist wenn man keine regierung hat falle schon raus ist.
Aber der aber nach den regel aber nach den regeln von den konservativen partei der parteichef muss ein abgeordnete sein das bedeutet er kann nicht mehr parteivorsitzende sein wenn er verliert seinen eigenen sitzt.
Ah das wäre also schon mal ein ganz interessanter angriff.
Und er hat den knappes mehrheit von einem premierminister seit der seit
fünfzig jahren oder so ist relativ knapp es gibt schon die erste überlegung die wechselt erstmal einen anderen wahlkreis damit er dann sich ist dass er noch immer bleiben kann.
Oh
Es geht aber diese art von spielereien.
Diese neuwahlen würden.
Wann frühestens stattfinden eine woche vor.
Woche vor dem austritt.
Das würde ja dann auch bedeuten.
Möglichen zeitpunkt oder eben auch eine woche später dann droht ja quasi wieder diese automatismus.
Wobei ich auch.
Gehört habe das sei auch sehr sehr umstritten wie es wie automatisch das jetzt ist aber das szenario wäre ja da und hätte auch automatisch entsprechende auswirkungen auf die wirtschaft et cetera und auf die debatte,
wie kann das parlament das verhindern.
Und wie kann kann oder konnte das parlament verhindern dass solche tricks die glaube ich dominik group in die welt geworfen hat mit diesem aussetzen des parlaments dieses pro ging.
Okay also das das wichtigste weg ist ein gesetz abzuschließen und das wäre dann bindend einfach mal.
Das premierminister muss machen bei mir es muss unbedingt nach brüssel gehen und und auf eine längere verlängerung bitten.
Zum beispiel wäre so eine option.
Oder den einseitigen ruck tritt des artikel fünfzig briefe es wäre auch möglich wenn das britische unterhaus adam zwei tagen vor dem austritt betreten nicht aus.
Johnson du musst nach busse gehen und und einfach mal sagen wir treten nicht aus das ist dann juristisch bindend.
Das problem ist wenn johnson das nicht tut.
Ja da geht es dann vor einem gericht und das wird dann dauert also man könnte es gibt das ist ein eins von den haben wir gesagt ist ein plan von dominik comics ist ja okay johnson tut einfach nicht was das britische unterhaus gesagt hatte.
Na also dann dann die großbritannien eine sehr tiefe konstitution alle krise weil,
wenn die was das ist was die getan haben im märz dieses jahr das unterhaus sowie den oberhaus hat ein gesetz abgestimmt geh mal nach brüssel um.
Um dann eine eine eine verlängerung zu kriegen also was wäre die einfachste weg nudeln kurzfristig zu stoppen einfach mal bitte brüssel erneut eine verlängerung.
Und was denkst du würde die eu darüber denken.
Dass man die eu die eu will ein so einfach so eine ende von dieses spiel.
Naja weil.
Egal wie.
Bisher bisher war es ja auch so diese verlängerung hat keinen so richtig gepasst aber es war auf jeden fall das kleinste übel und man hatte in gewisser hinsicht noch zeit.
Weil ja das eu budget der haushaltsplan.
Ja ja genau.
Noch eine weile gilt das läuft ja aber jetzt auch aus.
Servus.
Aus meiner sicht die eu wäre bereit großbritannien mehr zeit zu geben wenn großbritannien organisiert in wieder in und haus war oder ein zweites referendum.
Um mehr zeit zu kriegen einfach weil großbritannien mehr zeit braut.
Das wäre schwierig also ich gehe davon aus wenn das britische unterhaus einfach mal abstimmt okay wir brauchen mehr zeit.
Dass es könnte eine etwas härtere reaktion aus brüssel seite dann geben.
Sorry wir haben euch schon sechs monaten gegeben.
Es gibt es gibt und es gab kein keine lösung.
Jetzt brauchen wir klarheit und wir haben kein klarheit von euch also was wollt ihr also das wäre aus meiner sicht dann die reaktion das ist auch ein grund warum es ist meine hoffnung dass.
Also ein misstrauensvotum findet möglichst früh start weil dann gäbe es dann ein bisschen zeit für diese so hin in erst zwischen brüssel und und und london um.
Ein bisschen so herauszufinden was ist möglich und was nicht verwenden wenn johnson das britische unterhaus nehmen wir das beispiel das britische unterhaus.
Am dritten september schließt kein unterstütz kein misstrauensvotum und stattdessen.
Stimmt ein gesetz ab wir wollen kein nudel wir brauchen mehr zeit hier boris johnson schicken unser premierminister nach brüssel um um wir wollen noch eine verlängerung von sechs monaten,
wie reagiere dann die eu die eu werden sagt hey moment mal nein das geht nicht also wir brauchen klarheit denk mal darüber nach wie ihr da dann,
äh klarheit schafft in großbritannien also was bedeutet dann an an nicht die eu wird auf keinen fall sagen okay
es ist entweder ein misstrauensvotum oder ein unterhaus wahl oder ein referendum so konkret kann die eu nicht sein weil das das sieht so aus dass sie mischen sich in die die nationale demokratie ein aber die eu kann und will einfach nicht weiterhin war,
was geht.
Erfüllt genau die grunde wie gesagt hast oder brauchen großbritannien erneut ein ein europäische kommissar zum beispiel das neue,
kommission tritt am tag nach dem brexit am ersten november im amt,
oder ein brötchen kommissar wäre so was möglich nein also wenn große teile noch in der eu ist große timo muss noch ein kommissar nominieren.
Also die uhr tickt schon also und tick schon laut.
Na gut aber dann könnt ihr auch sagen okay wir gehen mal hier so eine verlängerung ihr bleibt jetzt noch zehn jahre.
Ja das wäre lustig ja ähm oder bis das nächste europawahl also ja.
Ja nur sehr lang niemandem hat das bis jetzt vorgeschlagen.
Vielleicht sollten wir das nach diesen podcast und schlagen das aus auslösung vor ja.
Gut ich meine letzte verlängerung war ja so maximal also wir hätten ja auch.
Na aber jetzt könnte man sozusagen sagen ja ihr bleibt jetzt mindestens noch bis zum nächsten europawahl kurz vorher und dann könnt ihr euch ja in der zwischenzeit was überlegen aber solange planen wir jetzt einfach den nächsten haushalt alles läuft jetzt einfach.
Ja an anscheinend brauchen braucht ihr deutlich mehr zeit weil gar nicht sein großbritannien funktioniert also wir geben euch entweder fünf jahren her oder nicht,
das wäre eine lust gelassen ich gehe nicht davon aus dass das macron sowas akzeptieren könnte.
Jetzt.
Gab es ja auch schon seit längerer zeit mit zunehmender unterstützung wenn auch noch nicht mit überschwänglich unterstützung die ganze diskussion um ein zweites referendum
als sozusagen die finale urteil über die ursprüngliche abstimmung die ja wie wir auch mehrfach ausgeführt haben
vor allem sehr unklar war ne man soll halt die eu verlassen aber niemand hat in irgendeiner form klar gesagt was denn nun das neue
hotel sein soll und bis heute gibt es ja dieses neue modell nicht und auch dieser ganze traum mit nur deal ist ja insofern auch absurd weil.
Gehen wir mal davon aus großbritannien würde am ersten november ausgetreten sein und es gibt keinen deal das erste was okay bräuchte wäre ein deal,
weil man hätte ja dann überhaupt gar keinen mehr nicht nur nicht mit den anderen sechsundzwanzig starten sondern man der eu sah man hätte vor allem auch keinen
mit den usa mit japan mit südamerika und so weiter
die eu ist weltmeister und hat irgendwie dazu mit der gesamten welt mittlerweile entsprechende abkommen also nicht unbedingt immer free track aber zumindest ein klar geregelten handelsbeziehung und,
okay hat einfach unterm strich nichts und könnte sozusagen überhaupt gar nicht mehr arbeiten.
Aber es gibt kein mehrheit der abgeordnete die für ein zweites referendum
und und ein volksbegehren oder so eine art system gibt's in großbritannien ja nicht das bedeutet eine sammlung von unterschriften oder so sowas so ein prozent zu starten geht nicht.
Es gibt es gäbe nur ein und haus wahl aus meiner sicht ein zweites referendum nach einer unter auswahl.
Was bedeutet es wenn ich dir dann in die in dem parteiprogramm der laber partei wenn wir dieses unterhaus war gewinnen organisieren wir dann ein zweites referendum also das wäre den einzigen weg so ein zweites referendum.
Das wird dann auf jeden fall ein argument was die teams anführen würden ganz klar.
Das unterstützen die dass die grünen sind stutzen nationales aber das ist die große frage zeichnest,
unterstütze label sowas weil es gibt diese laibe abgeordneten aus aus wahlkreis im norden england es waren mehrheit der der der wähler für den brexit gestimmt haben die sind.
Die sind die haben so ein bündnis gegründet innerhalb der partei rundum steven also der sohn von der ehemalige parteichef
oder oder oder oder so was heißt das das diese menschen obwohl die leber abgeordneten sind die sind gegen ein zweites referendum,
ja die wollen keine nudel die wollen ein geregeltes brexit mit ein deal und die wollen kein zweites referendum also was wäre dann die position von dieser abgeordneten,
wenn ein zweites,
wenn ein unter stattfindet könnten die dann hundertprozentig eine lady die die linie der labor partei überhaupt unterstützen wissen wir auch nicht also,
den weg so ein zweites referendum ist,
noch sehr schwierig und man könnte,
aber davon bin ich optimistisch wenn ein zweites referendum stattfindet man könnte sowas will man gewinnen,
also es gibt steigende unterstützung für einen verbleib in der eu also da hab ich ein gewisser optimismus mein skepsis muss es ist,
wie findet man ein weg überhaupt zu den zweiten referendum sekunde also das ist die idee die große frage.
Der weg würde also dann über die neuwahlen gehen ja,
ja dann gibt's ja noch im prinzip zwei andere referenten die im raum stehen wir hatten das letzte sendung auch schon paar mal angesprochen und das.
Beiden eine geringere wahrscheinlichkeit ausgesprochen aber hier können wir da vielleicht auch mal eine neue bewertung,
vornehmen zunächst einmal gibt es ja nordirland und im
freitags abkommen ist ja festgehalten dass das land im prinzip das recht hat ein neues referendum irland weit durchzuführen,
wenn sich das weiß ich ganz genau wie die formulierung ist wenn sich abzeichnet wenn wahrnehmbar ist wenn's irgendwie erfüllbar ist dass es unter umständen,
andere mehrheit gibt als es da bisher gab die bisherige mehrheit war natürlich einfach der im referendum ja auch festgeschrieben kompromiss,
nationalität spielt hier eigentlich keine rolle mehr man kann ihrer sein man kann brite sein hauptsache,
keine grenze und gleiches wirtschaftssystem etcetera notier würde das auflösen und würde natürlich in
der hinsicht auch eine juristische krise
innerhalb des britischen rechtssystem ja auch herbei beschwören weil ja nur die eigentlich die er mit ral zu diesem abgeschlossenen internationalen vertrag
mit irland und der eu stehen würde.
Angenommen wir hätten jetzt eine situation in der tatsächlich ein solches referendum angestrebt werden würde.
Das ist natürlich schon mal fraglich aber ich habe mich gefragt wenn es das gäbe,
wie würde es ausgehen muss ja dazu sagen es wäre nicht ein referendum sondern technischen wenn's ja zwei,
eins in nordirland eins in der republik irland zeitgleich mit derselben fragestellung und nur wenn beide ja sagen mehrheitlich dann wäre es tatsächlich so dass nordirland verlassen würde und teil der republik irland wird.
Ja ich bin noch skeptisch ob.
Man sowas kurzfristig organisieren könnte,
es gibt keine ernsthafte diskussionen darüber zurzeit weil nordirland herausfinden wie funktioniert brexit und was für ein einfluss hat brexit auf die note richtig grenze,
also im falle eine nudel,
dann könnte unterstützung für so eine referendum in nur in irland rasant steigen was wir sehen in oder haben wir gesehen haben bei der europawahl in nordirland.
War.
Also das bedeutet statt die traditionellen protestanten tische und katholische parteien.
Parteien die,
keine klare position oder euch zu diese religiösen spannungen nehmen die party zum beispiel die kam auf den dritten platz und die waren traditionell den fünf größten partei nordirland so so man sieht
obwohl man es nicht hört in japan technische bande warte man sieht in nordirland in gewisse pragmatismus wir wollen.
Was wir haben es hat eigene maßen funktioniert,
das wollen wir unbedingt so das war dann ein nein nein nein nein ein priorität also ich denk dann
wir müssen uns mal sehen was passiert mit brexit was passiert an der grenze dann mittelfristig.
Wie sieht es dann aus aber ich gehe davon aus dass nicht vor zwanzig zweiundzwanzig frühestens so ein referendum da stattfinden könnte.
Ja und und und bricht so spannungen gewalt oder so in nordirland wieder aus nicht unmöglich also die sind die großen fragen aber.
Alles im,
in in die richtige reihenfolge also zuerst die diskussion starten ja schon aber keine richtig ernsthafte debatten über ein zweites.
Alles klar das ist natürlich zu irgendeiner entscheidung im brexit fall kommen würde ich hab mich nur gefragt und wir haben jetzt eben auch eigentlich im wesentlichen über die nordirakischen perspektive gesprochen aber es gibt ja auch noch die irische perspektive und.
Die sind dagegen dafür und dagegen die sind die mussten offiziell die muss noch effizienter für eine wiedervereinigung sein aber.
Wie wollen sie sich den schuh nicht anziehen.
Es bringt dir genau es bringt ja probleme weil nordirland ist deutlich.
Radikale regional religiös gesehen als ihr land selbst nordirland ist ein drittel pro kopf bruttoinlandsprodukt pro kopf,
ärmer aus irland das bedeutet man hatte dann so eine deutsche wiedervereinigung problem.
Also es wäre nicht ohne problemen für irland das sind so wieder zu vereinigen,
das haben einige schon ein bisschen so erläutert in den dublin also mal eine referendum könnte man doch gewinnen in irland es wäre schwierig das zu gewinnen in nordirland ehm aber ja es wäre nicht ohne probleme.
Es wäre nicht ohne probleme aber es wäre natürlich auch eine interessante chance hier für die eu,
wiederum einen punkt zu machen zumal sie ja nun schon für das karfreitag abkommen,
verantwortlich waren das jetzt halt sagen okay alles klar wiedervereinigung das unterstützen wir jetzt mal so richtig und wir kippen da mal ganz viel geld und politische energie rein um.
Auch ein interessantes aspekt also den vereinigten staaten waren auch ein teil von die verhandlungen für das karfreitag das abkommen es gibt ein netz so
repräsentatives irische herkunft in den im kongress in in den freien staaten und die haben alle gesagt hey moment mal wir geben großbritannien kein freitag kein
freihandelsabkommen nach dem austritt wenn das k freitags abkommen scheitert wegen brexit.
So sehr interessant es war nur recht publika der der das gesagt hatte hey pass auf hier wenn brexit bedeutet kein frieden mehr nordirland oder ist eine harte grenze da gebe dann moment mal wir verhandeln,
wir haben die amerikaner gesagt ich war das fand ich ein sehr interessantes aspekt.
Nicht die regierung sondern halt.
And congress muss ein freihandelsabkommen zustimmen und sogar republikaner in kongress waren äh gegen bescheiden des vereins letztes karfreitag sabbert.
Und die demokraten sind sowieso auf.
Genau genau genau.
Sieht irgendwie nicht gut aus dafür.
Ja ja das ist das problematisch und dann natürlich natürlich gibt's an einen anderen referendum das in schottland
da jetzt vor kurzem erneut meinungsumfrage.
Steigende unterstützung für einen unabhängigen schottland also,
die frage ist da auch wie findet man ein weg so ein zweites referendum auch ein problem wenn großbritannien geht mit einen brexit raus aus der eu und schaut man will dann bleiben
man man hat dann dieses problem der nordirakischen grenze hätte man dann auch an der schottische,
englische grenze und da gab es keine grenzkontrollen seit siebzehn hundertsieben also dann eine harte grenze da einzuführen das will niemand also man hatte dann mal wieder so dann den start in nordirakischen backstube dann den schottischen backstage sorgen ähm und da haben wir auch keine keine
ideen wie du wie das wie das funktionieren könnte also das bedeutet auch also die warten ja in schottland
und dann ich sehe dann mittelfristig können sondern zweites referendum dann stattfinden aber dann das dann auch erst zwanzig zweiundzwanzig.
Das wäre der wiederaufbau des adrian wals.
Ja genau ja ja den neuen in den den hardware soll mauer.
Die mauer fand ich insofern ganz lustig als dass er dann sozusagen gar nicht wahr um und die schatten irgendwie einzusperren sondern es war ja nicht die schotten den gebaut haben um sich zu von den römern zu schützen sondern es war die römer die gebaut haben um sich von den schotten.
Zeigt immer wieder schön dieser widerstand wille schottland dann doch extrem stark ist politisch habe ich auch den eindruck
die fdp ist nach wie vor oben auf mit nikola es deutschland haben sie immer noch jemanden der klar kommuniziert klar,
eine vertretbar e politik an den tag legt und schottland auch mitzieht auf,
weg also dass das sozusagen das land eigentlich.
Willkommen zu.
Ganz klar da immer noch auf so einer offenen lösung ist.
Das das das stimmt oh man man sieht auch.
Indischen versuche in also der der der premierminister von wales designlabor abgeordnete aber da herrscht eine etwas stärkere,
so gegen brexit position und auch man sah das erste protest für einen unabhängigen im sommer so so zehntausend menschen also nicht
unglaublich groß aber schon was
also da da sagt man auch steigende unterstützung für die begleitung mehr so die realistische nationalisten weil sie sehen was grad
passiert in schottland die wollen ein anderes politik in wales es gibt dann so es kommt schon was für einen unabhängigen also das ist auch interessant
also da das bild da braucht man ein paar jahrzehnte bis man den punkt erreicht dann ein referendum zu den themen organisieren aber das fand ich auch beeindruckt.
Ja weil wirklich mit england auf einer art und weise zusammenhängt die ist mit schottland und mit nordirland überhaupt nicht zu vergleichen,
ist sehr klein und man hat eigentlich nur diesen relativ dünnen industriellen süd streifen und der rest ist im wesentlichen wald und.
Und und viele schafe.
Und.
Ja ja aber aber aber aber mein mann mann mann sahen die letzten also meine eltern wohnen in potential also das kann ich so ein bisschen so von fern beobachten.
Es gab eine eigene politische community so in kader es seitdem nein die sind diese gründung den politischen sample nach den referendum siebenundneunzig.
Also,
eine eigene politische kultur hat sich da entwickelt in den letzten zwanzig jahren in kader und daraus hat man hat man da schon vielleicht dann würzeln von okay
hier wir können politik ein bisschen anders machen also da gibt's schon mehr so eine.
Eigene realistisches politik heutzutage erst vor zwanzig jahren nicht genug um unabhängig zu sein aber das könnte doch kommen.
Aber es ist nicht so kleine vergreifen so es gibt drei millionen einwohner fünfeinhalb den job machen also und drei millionen einwohner wäre größer als manche mitgliedstaat der eu wie es land oder oder luxemburger.
Jetzt äh haben wir natürlich auch die situation mit den wahlen in usa nächstes jahr wo,
ich glaube ich immer noch sehr unklar ist sowohl wer jetzt bei den demokraten gegen trump antritt und auch unklar ist ob er denn dann sozusagen auch
es schafft trump zu besiegen
nach diesen ganzen skandalen und juristischen verfolgung ist zumindest klar wir werden jetzt also diese amtszeit noch aussitzen müssen und dieses ganze zusammenspiel von lief und dem trump planen
war ja auch sehr offensichtlich cambridge analytica da gibt es also eine ja ich würd schon fast sagen sondern etwas nervöse verstrickungen auf diese achse
die sich natürlich noch stärken oder abschwächen kann das ist derzeit sehr schwer einzuschätzen ich bin so ein bisschen unruhig geworden als ich dieses ganze säbelrasseln jetzt mit dem iran.
Habe mit beschlagnahmt tanken jetzt letzter move irgendwie das jetzt die breite dieser iranische,
wieder freigegeben wurde.
Welche rolle spielt derzeit okay international hier
noch früher wäre das ja irgendwie ein ganz dickes ding gewesen jetzt habe ich so ein bisschen den eindruck das ganze hat er seine schlagkraft verloren auch weil die usa.
Ihre diplomatische schlagkraft ja im prinzip selbst aufgegeben haben trotzdem existiert ja diese britische amerikanische achse
quasi jetzt derzeit so doppelt einerseits über boris johnson trump ja sicherlich irgendwie noch eher miteinander können als eben auch in dieser ganzen traditionellen verbindung mal von der sprache ganz
abgesehen wie schätzt du diese internationale situation die diplomatische rolle derzeit ein ist die.
Also die höchste priorität großbritannien zur zeit ist wo findet man überhaupt variiert also es geht nicht mit der eu,
wir brauchen was irgendwo und wir brauchen auch wenn es geht auch handelsabkommen.
Also das ist dann ein höchstes priorität das bedeutet das aber dann,
man muss auch nicht vergessen dass wenn man schaut in die brötchen bewölkung,
briten sie nicht besonders mehr pro amerikanisch,
aus aller anderen europäischen länder so sei der irak-krieg gibt's großen problemen also müssen wir unbedingt machen was die amerikaner wollen
also die britische regierung ist mehr pro amerikanisches die britische
bevölkerung so das macht dann der der situation für thompson dann relativ schwierig,
und diese situation also es gab dieses fall vor dem gericht in gibraltar so wäre
wir haben jetzt kein kein kunde mehr dass dieses tanke hier noch bleibt dieses tanke muss dann frei gegeben werden.
Und dann stand großbritannien es gab dieses dieses fahrrädern vor einem gericht in new york ja so unbedingt das das geht ja nicht aber große anscheinend großbritannien lässt jetzt dieses tanke dann frei.
Und auch vollkommen zu recht die haben keine begründung dass das noch äh festzuhalten grobe,
die kommt die britische konservativen brauchen trump weil die brauchen schon für ein freihandelsabkommen und die wollen auch so ein gewinn oder sowas also meine zeichen dass die noch nicht alleine auf der welt sind,
also das sind die prioritäten aber die die britische bewölkung ist es ist noch relativ skeptisch,
gegenüber es ist nicht einfach dass die briten unterstützen was die wirkung unterstützt was die regierung in in dieser in dieser situation wählen.
Welche verbündeten hatte dann überhaupt noch derzeit.
Es ist eine ernsthafte lage weil.
Also mit trump ist natürlich sehr schwierig so cola variieren auch für johnson weil trump ist bereit,
so für den vereinigten staaten zu kämpfen und alles und nerven also der tut nicht nichts weil,
johnson so ein freund ist der david was tun weil es in den wirtschaftlichen interessen der vereinigten staaten ist ja und was mache das britische agrarindustrie zum beispiel kaputt.
Mit eu-länder es geht überhaupt nicht auch mit ländern sind zentrale in osteuropa die spannung mit russland sei den skripal in großbritannien sind noch schlechter geworden.
Auch die so ehemalige kolonial länder kanada australien und so die sonja so unsere priorität ist handelsabkommen mit der eu nicht mit nicht mit euch da in in in in großbritannien.
Ja also es,
situation mit indien ist auch ganz kompliziert weil die beine mode der will,
mehr wiesn für kinder nachher nach großbritannien kriegt er ja nicht von die britische regierung.
Also was bedeutet der welt lage für großbritannien ist nicht besonders einfach zu zeigen.
Ja hongkong echt problematisch ja weil dominik war bei oder oder oder also ist schon sogar hand vor vor noch außenminister war ja so es geht beim.
Es gibt eine besondere demokratische tradition in hongkong hat er so gesagt und dann stand dann große tannen unter druck wer so mich mich euch nicht mehr einmal bei uns bitte,
also mit schiene geht's auch nicht so besonders gut.
Nicht mehr viel übrig japan hatten wir auch schon irgendwie.
Ja ich mein japan ist kompliziert wegen dem die japanische autofabrik in großbritannien oder so.
Ja am großbritannien hat zurzeit nicht so viele gute freunde.
Ne also ich glaube das ist das einzige land was ich,
entdeckt habe die sich über den brexit freuen würden sie die verrühre inseln.
Ja ja die haben auch ein ein freihandelsabkommen sowohl schon.
Also die könnten da total von profitieren aber das war's dann.
Ja
Glaub nicht dass jetzt okay und wie unbedingt die ganze welt gegen die.
Ja und dann werden wir an was sind die bewölkung von den zwanzig zwanzig dreißigtausend einwohner ja dass das rettet die deutsche wirtschaft nicht.
Ist nicht viel der ist glaube ich auch nicht die kriegt gerade so mühe und not eine fußballmannschaft zusammen,
war das wasser auch schon.
Ja einundzwanzigtausend gut.
Keine verbündeten für großbritannien ciao.
Was denkst du ist jetzt was sind jetzt so die.
Möglicherweise mit entscheidenden faktoren außerhalb großbritanniens was kann deutschland frankreich.
Also jetzt mal unabhängig von der eu als,
player die jetzt in irgendeiner form überhaupt noch irgendwas bieten mit diskutieren anbieten verhandeln können.
Ich gehe ich hab auf die belegt was was könnte business tun,
wenn nissan entscheidet okay wir schließen diese riesen autofabrik in holland oder airbus schließt schließt dieses fabrik in ähm in in in norden wo die fertigen die trag flügeln von äh von.
Ja und in brüssel auch.
Ja genau also die die die die die die ähm die motoren ja das ist ein bisschen einfacher zu transportieren es war schon ein paar problem die trauben zu transportieren aus nur.
Was wäre dann die reaktion also schon die reaktion sowieso hunde war ja so ja das ist schade aber wir haben unsere eigene ecken und wirtschaftliche zukunft außerhalb der eu,
oder wenn irgendein industrie jetzt pleite geht oder oder oder großbritannien verlässt ich denke das hat das hat das das hätte in den kommenden monaten fast keine auswirkung auf die brille auf die debatte null.
Ich habe angst dass.
Johnson es alles dann überlebt bis oktober und dann ist oder eine nudel und die eu sagt okay wir geben euch dann was.
Ich denke die chancen sie sehr gering dass die eu das tut.
Aber es besteht noch eine chance dass die eu sagt hey moment mal nudel ist einfach zu gefährlich.
Wir geben johnson irgendwas ohne kommt so in der großbritannien und falls irgendein sieg also dass das da hab ich angst
dass es könnte dann wirtschaftliche wirtschaftliches druck dann geben aus anderen länder der eu auf merkel oder auf die niederländer oder auf
die schwedische region hey moment mal also lieber irgendein deal auch wenn es ein schlechtes ist,
statt ein aber wie du vorher gesagt hast.
Auch im falle einer studie brauche großbritannien kurz danach irgendeinen übergang stil also.
Ich gehe davon aus dass die eu bleibt auf die gleiche liebe die gleiche linie aber ich habe eine gewisse angst dass es könnte kippen,
ja vielleicht nicht im september sondern in oktober.
Gibts was anderes gäbe es irgendeine andere krise in großbritannien die königin.
Oder sowas oder großbritannien ist irgendwie überhaupt nicht in der lage keine ahnung es gibt überschwemmungen oder ein viertel mausi oder so oder so
so was wünsche ich natürlich nicht aber das ist das,
gäbe es dann ein weg großbritannien so noch tiefer in die krise rein zu stürzen oder nur schlechte wirtschaftlichen zahlen damit ist klar es ist großbritannien stecke dann in einem in einer rezeption,
so die sind die er die einzigen dingen die dieses diese situation irgendwie beeinflussen oder oder oder endeten könnt.
Ist ganz lustig dass du das sagst mit der queen also ich meine man hat sich ja,
glaube ich in großbritannien einerseits so ein bisschen daran gewöhnt dass sie eigentlich nicht stirbt.
Aber sie ist schon drei.
Ja sie ist irgendwie pornos aber es ist ja auch noch relativ klar also ist ja jetzt nicht dass sie die bienen nur noch herum läuft und ein bisschen rum winkt sondern ich kann auch noch ganze sätze sprechen und es soweit ich das einschätzen kann noch her der situation,
aber sie repräsentiert ja auch mehr nur als diese konkrete teilt politische rolle die sie noch hat sie repräsentiert ja auch all das.
Was.
Ganz am anfang besprochen haben dieses empire dieses dieser nationale stolz dieses dieses gefühl dass.
Zusammenhalt großbritanniens auch.
Ja so und teufel dich an die wand malen und ich habe mir überlegt so ja was was wäre denn wenn sie jetzt stirbt was wäre also was wäre wenn sie jetzt stirbt,
was wäre das irgendwie so eine so eine botschaft irgendwie der himmel öffnet sich und.
Euer ja jetzt ist großbritannien auch wirklich zu ende.
Chaos ist nicht so politisch klug also der mich sich in den alltag action politik häufiger ein also es könnte mittelfristig problematische sein.
Er denn übernehmen.
Ja klar.
Hatte er dich gesagt dass er das.
Ich hatte nie also es gab gerüchte dass er lässig da das an seinem sohn aber aber das hat er bestätigt da hat sich sein ganzes leben auf dieses moment vorbereitet da gibt es jetzt nicht auf nee kein problem auf keinen fall.
Er war immer schon so ein bisschen der im parlament ist.
Ja aber aber grob.
Kurzfristig das bedeutet dann so eine periode der nationale trauer ein paar wochen also das mit einem mitten ineinander in der brexit krise also ähm ja dass das da da brauche großbritannien einen brexit verlängerung.
Ist tot ja.
Ne also aber aber mittelfristig also.
Aber würde wenn er wenn er die rolle des königs dann wäre auch alles anders die hymne wäre dann king und so weiter es wird alles geändert werden.
Ja ja gott sei dank.
Ja ja,
und wenn er mehr politische position beziehen würden.
Da könnte dann in die debatte starten also brauchen wir ein neues rechte das macht die königliche familie zu begrenzen.
Aber ich meine die rolle auf dem papier haben sie diese ja also ich meine.
Ja aber aber aber aber die königin hast du so kluge spiel ja also die königin ins im jahr des geburt meine mutter königin geworden ja also,
auf meine mutter kennt gar nichts anderes ja auf was du so meine großeltern haben gar nichts anderes bekannt ja also das bedeutet es,
wir.
Wir wissen ja nicht auf den brexit wir können es ja wissen theoretisch gesehen ja also sagen wir zehn abgeordneten trainer aus der konservativen.
Es gibt ja gebe dann ein misstrauensvotum und ist da nicht klar wer eine mehrheit hier dann in wm und haus hat johnson hat es ja nicht anscheinend wenn auch nicht.
Wer lädt die königin ein um eine regierung zu bilden.
Denn dieses macht hat die königin ja na ja berater bestimmt es wird ihnen die presse dann schon bekannt gegeben also keine ahnung klar karte höhe chancen aus hameln oder so,
aber aber die macht hat die königin,
also es könnte dann in die debatte dann schauen in so inwiefern ist großbritannien überhaupt noch eine eine eine moderne ein modernes land dass so viel mache ich noch bei dir bei die königliche familie und das großbritannien bauch auch,
unbedingt eine schriftliche verfassung was es noch nicht.
Das ist ja mein ausblick.
Das sind interessante fragen für die zukunft.
Allein deshalb müssen sie noch.
Machen wir noch wenn du entweder die königin so wie soll man das auf deutsch so tritt zurück.
Abtritt und wenn die königin abtritt machen wir dann noch ein podcast zu die zukunft die britische verfassung situation nachdem die zeit das können.
Ich denke wir sind mit dem thema hier sowieso noch nicht durch irgendwie also jetzt müssen wir erstmal abwarten was passiert wenn das parlament neu antritt.
Und dann ja denke ich wird sich die gelegt nächste gelegenheit schon finden dieses spannenden prozess weiter zu begleiten aber ich glaube erstmal schluss.
Ja gut alles klar ja ja.
Schon vielen dank.
Und ja das war's von mir heute demnächst da nochmal ein anderes thema denke ich hoffe ich.